you the people have spoken
and it is resounding
marcos junior
[Music]
ferdinand marcus
who reigned over the philippines for
more than 21 years he took advantage of
the uncertainties of the cold war to
impose his own order
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they have been presenting this
really clinically whitewashed image of
of the marcos era that had the
philippines not have the pesky etsa
revolution we would have been now a
singapore i once knew a man
who saw what little had been achieved
since independence
in a land of people with the greatest
potential for achievement and yet
they were poor
but he got it done so he projects this
very soft image
and that allowed him to essentially use
this strong man marcus bran plus his own
laid laid-back charisma and create this
whole new hybrid of a brand which is now
appealing to a huge section of the
philippine society
[Music]
we're essentially still stuck
with the problems that we inherited
whether it's debt whether it's
institutional erosion whether it's
corruption of the judiciary and state
institutions none of that was
significantly improved they had 21 years
to do whatever they wanted in the
philippines run it like their personal
fiefdom and the fear right now is that
they're going to do the same thing i
think they're definitely here to erase
the legacy of the 1996 revolution
[Music]
you